نبدا المنتصف من روسيا اذ اعلن الكريم ان
اتفاقيه تصدير الحبوب عبر البحر الاسود قد
انتهت بالنسبه لروسيا واوضح ان موسكو
ستعود على الفور الى الاتفاق بمجرد تلبيه
مطالبها وشرى الكريم الى انها موقف روسيا
من اتفاق الحبوب جاء قبل الهجوم على جسر
القرم ووصف الحادثه بالعمل الارهابي الذي
لن يؤثر على قرار موسكو بدورها قالت
المتحدثه باسم الخارجيه الروسيه الناريه
ان بلادها ابلغت تركيا واوكرانيا والامم
المتحده قرار رفضها تمديد اتفاق تصدير
الحبوب الاوكرانيه
هذا وقد اعلنت الخارجيه الروسيه ان مبادره
البحر الاسود للحبوب تتوقف عن العمل غدا
الثلاثاء واضافت الخارجيه الروسيه ان صفقه
الحبوب لم تحقق الهدف الانسانيه المرجو
منها وانها تمديدها فقد معناه في ظل ما
وصفته بالتخريب الواضح وقالت الخارجيه
الروسيه ان روسيا تسحب الضمانات الامنيه
في ممر البحر الاسود